what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today we are going to
watch
our buddy paul over at heavy spoilers
since we are
gonna shoot loki episode five reaction
tonight at midnight hopefully have that
up for you guys
early wednesday morning we're like you
know what let's let the games continue
with the theories and all that why
miss minutes controls the tva and is the
real
big villain let's see what's in store
baby
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
mr eight minute video so i can get more
youtube ads in it
and something has been itching away
let's make a video discussing all of the
things in loki that probably won't come
true
and this included a lot of talking
points amongst these were why the
post-credits scene might just be a
garbage timeline people get sent to and
pruned
and also how ravono rensselaer may be a
lucky variant
lots of click bait however one thing i
said flippantly
actually seems more and more likely the
more i think about it
what if the big bad of the entire show
has been hiding in plain sight this
entire time
and it is possible that miss minutes may
be the one controlling the tva
i'm going to pause this super quick i'm
very curious to see what he has to say
because this is
in particular one of the theories that
he presented we were like
way the most dismissive about this one
yeah yeah
let's see if we can convince us since
saying it i've had a lot of people reach
out to me
saying they agree and men's health even
did an article about it so if it's
away and true then i'm going to lose
everything my reputation
everything i'm going to lose it however
yeah i think there might be a lot of
characteristics that she portrays
which could demonstrate exactly why she
is the one pulling the strings
okay just talking about things on a meta
level miss minutes is a brand new
character that hasn't featured in the
comics before
because of this her inclusion doesn't
give anything away
and it's weird that they would invent a
whole character just to have them
basically do a psa in episode 1
and a couple of lines in episode 2.
behind her vocal performance is taurus
strong
an a-lister when it comes to voice
actors and she's betrayed harley quinn
that girl the powerpuff girls and a lot
of characters a lot of people she's a
big name in the industry
that i think most people will have heard
of before and it seems strange that
they'd get her in to just do a couple of
lines
for what is seemingly an insignificant
character see i just don't think that's
that big of a deal
it's a featured character it's the
marvel show why wouldn't she do it
in a cartoon style yeah someone is a
veteran cartoon voice
yeah like to me it's just it lines up
we're debating with you paul marvel has
done big casting
many times before sometimes you get
oscar-winning actors in there and they
don't do anything yeah cameo and asgard
next we have to talk about what her role
in the tva
is i've been talking to ryan airy from
screencrush about this
and yes spoiler alert we do actually get
on well which
no doubt will confirm many fan theories
that our listeners have
now we've gone back and forth over the
individual role of miss minutes
and how she's central to the tva
restoring order amongst the chaos that
is existence
in episode 1 miss minutes presents the
introduction that details all the ins
and outs of the timekeepers
who we learn a machine simply put in
place to keep up the facade
in the second entry we see that she's
very much been propped up to make sure
that the variants follow her guidelines
in order to ensure that the sacred
timeline is kept in place
she clearly controls the messaging the
propaganda if you will
and in a fascist state that is where the
majority of power lies
the only way to have people follow a
leader like they're a deity
is to present them as one and miss
minutes is central to this messaging
the tva themselves put in place to
blindly follow orders
and we also see through minutes that she
can appear on any tv screen in the
organization
or even upon people's desks if she needs
to but she could just be an ai
that was also created to communicate the
information
yeah this helps create the illusionify
explainers for this situation yeah the
only thing
honestly that makes me wonder right now
is because they took the time to have
loki be like are you alive
or are you just a recording and for her
to actually answer the question
i mean even that i'm like yeah she could
just be a really good computer
simulation to make
all of this propaganda seem a lot more
fun the way that she works and the
powers that she possesses
is something that has a lot of question
marks surrounding it
and at the moment we still have no clue
exactly how she operates
is she live streaming is she a recording
that looks at live
responses after an event and edits
herself to continue the sleep of actions
we just don't know but yeah either way
something is off about her
she seems like a cute and cuddly
character with a disarming southern
accent
however there is a darker side to her we
get a hint towards this during episode
one
when we see a poster that says behave or
you'll get your clock cleaned
this has an image of her stamping on
someone which is something that's often
used in propaganda to present power
those that step out of line and don't
behave in the way that she wants them
and the idea of her being powerful is
clearly laced throughout this scene
interestingly in the episode before loki
joins the queue
they scan to see if he's a robot we
learn that those that
are are immediately wiped out and this
could be because a robot might have the
capability to scan its environment
and it would immediately see if the
timekeepers are mechanical or not
being a machine herself miss minutes
would know this
so she would likely want to erase all
possibility of a robot coming face to
face with her
right before the variance to for the
first time yes yes miss minutes would
want to
but you could also say whoever else is
running the ship here would want to and
probably could have programmed miss
minutes to act in accordance with
its motivation i guess i haven't heard a
solid theory from anyone yet what
what being miss minutes might actually
be other than some creation
from whomever is really calling the
shots yeah just like another mouthpiece
if they were able to do that with the
time keepers they could easily do that
with miss bits
unless they want her to be the next
ultron now going beyond this clocks are
of course central to not only time
but the tva itself they are constantly
watching over the timeline
and thus a clock being in charge of how
time plays out makes a lot of sense on a
symbolic level
clocks of course mark time in a linear
fashion with everything flowing in one
strict direction
thus her being behind it lines up a lot
with the way that clocks work
the entire tva city looks like the inner
workings of a clock
there are a lot of gears and people all
in their specific place so that
overall the timeline can continue to
move in a certain direction
we can also see on the elevator panel
that there is a floor which goes
directly to her
and this could be foreshadowing where
the finale takes place
on top of this is the fact that the
timekeepers themselves are robots
and we know that she is connected to
them in some way
besides them she's the only other power
figure in the organization
and the fact that they're fugazi leaves
her as the only thing left in the
position to control things
now every time i've told this theory to
someone they've either said you you son
of a [ __ ] you've done it
or said that it sucks i think this is
because she's basically just a talking
clock
and people want someone big like kang
the conqueror whilst this is true and i
have been on board the kang train myself
i'm just looking at the pieces that are
currently on the board and
we have been introduced to miss minutes
whereas he's something that probably
won't be in the show
well i could fathom how like maybe if
ravana rensselaer is connected to king
the conqueror whoever is really calling
the shots
maybe it is whoever is embodying miss
minutes yeah you know what i mean
if they do a reveal and it's tara strong
you know you're strong
stepping onto the screen yeah you know
something like that i could buy that
i get wise people believe this theory
it's like i said there's nothing behind
it though that i'm really
getting into like who is the face of
miss minutes who what is the being of
miss
you know whose voice speaks through the
charming clock avatar
if it is like a wizard of oz type deal
you know
yeah now some big spoilers from one of
the trailers going forward
so if you want to go into the upcoming
episodes as blind as possible
then i highly recommend that you prune
yourself from the timeline also if
you've enjoyed the theories then the
thumbs up is much appreciated
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns on the show each and every
week
now if you're still here yet thank you
for sticking with me and
staying in line with the kang theory it
may be revealed that minutes is actually
an avatar for the villain
in either the fifth or sixth episode we
do know that mobius heads out to egypt
and fans of the comics will know this
ties in heavily with kang's backstory
over the years he's gone by many names
including rama tut
which was his pseudonym when he reigned
as a pharaoh in ancient egypt
nathaniel richards to give him his birth
name was born in the 30th century
however he ended up using a time machine
to travel back to 2960 bc
here he left several things including a
prophecy about apocalypse
aka the first mutant and he also took
over a vast kingdom
kang was able to do this with ease
through his highly advanced technology
and it does make a lot of sense that
mobius would travel there to learn about
him
now overall this one is outside it's
a certain way without coming out and
saying exactly who it is
if miss minutes is revealed to be the
one behind it all and then we get
someone behind that
it does tease enough for the future
without making it so that the audience
who aren't aware of kang
aren't completely lost they can still
watch the show and see the seeds sown
before the big reveal
and for me that makes the most sense
especially now we know how marvel tend
to set their villains up in these shows
either way there's a lot to talk about
in this video and if it turns out to be
untrue then i'm wiping everyone's
memories who's watched this
so never bring it up again until then
though i'd love to hear your thoughts on
these theories i made it's a great video
though paul
it's a well laid out argument and a lot
of people are on your side when it comes
to this one
i would love to be wrong i love being
like oh damn i didn't see another
episode
for reaction like oh what bro i didn't
think there'd be any robot whoa
i was wrong and i could get excited when
i'm wrong
they can still catch you off guard we'll
see we'll see how it goes miss minutes
is definitely the time clearly by the
like to dislike ratio on this
video of yours we're in the minority
here
so it's definitely miss minute yeah
we'll talk behind the scenes a little
bit more too we'll argue about it
and he'll defriend me and i'm sorry all
right
well guys subscribe to happy spoilers if
you have done so already fastest man
with the breakdowns out there
for all these marvel shows click that
notification bell hit that like button
you can check out our reaction to
another video that he did uh loki
episode 5 series where he covered a wide
variety of other theories and something
that got me
very excited so yeah
foxy fox fox i think
if anyone on our patreon could be behind
miss minutes it would be
you because you're a badass but you're
also
you know kind of a nerd you know you're
probably good with machinery you could
probably slip inside a computer you know
make your way
all through the time variance authority
and then when we get to the actual miss
minutes floor
this is you working out finding great
gifts to send our way and then you know
the whole show just becomes about
our relationship and then everybody else
who's watching is like what
what is this inside joke i don't get it
i mean first ralph boner now this like
the show was on such a roll and then we
met this fox character
who seems like a really great person by
the way would love to see a spin-off
series just about her
but for the purposes of loki a little
bit of a weird twist
but hey i would be all about that twist
so fox i hope you're doing well i always
appreciate your comments feedback
especially on the psych videos and
whatnot even when you comment back and
just talk to yourself
i love your feedback each and every time
so hope you're doing well and thanks
again for that massager
and the bracelet it's awesome
[Music]